in the previous video we began our study
of ABC watch Factory and we tried to
understand the economics of the business
based on some data that we had already
collected on our costs and how much
output we can produce based on how many
labor units we had and then from that we
calculated things like the marginal
product of labor the marginal cost the
average variable cost the average fixed
cost and the average total cost what
we're going to do in this video is take
this information especially total output
and all of these things that we just
calculated and we're going to graph it
so that we can better appreciate how
these various calculations and the
curves that we can get from the
calculations are interrelated so let me
scroll over a little bit so we have some
space and then let me set up a little
coordinate plane here and so what we
have on our vertical axis this is our
cost and then down here in our
horizontal axis this is our output so
first let's just hand graph it and I
encourage you to go through the exercise
yourself it's one thing to watch me do
it but when you actually graph something
you digest the numbers that much better
and so let's start with marginal cost
and I'm going to do it in this blue
green color so let's see when our total
output is 25 our marginal cost is 267 so
when our output is 25 - 67 would be
right about there and we're just trying
to get be able to visualize what's going
on and then when our total output is 45
our marginal cost is 150 dollars so 45
is here and then 150 is right about
there and then when our total output is
58 our marginal cost is 231 so 58 is
right about there and then it's going to
be 231 so it's about right about there
and then when our total output is 65 our
marginal cost is 4
29 so 65 is right over there and then
429 will get us right about right about
there
so we see our marginal cost is going up
a lot now might be a little bit lower
than that so it's gonna be right over
there and then last but not least when
our total output is 70 our marginal cost
is $600 so at 70 we get to 600 and I'm
eyeballing it now it's not exact graph
paper but this gives you a sense of what
the marginal cost curve looks like and
here we've kind of graphed it based on
where we are in terms of output so
that's our marginal marginal cost curve
so I'll just label that marginal cost
and now let's see how that relates to
the curves for average variable cost and
average total cost so average variable
cost I'll do in this orange color so at
an output of 25 our average variable
cost is $240 so 25 we are going to be at
240 dollars which is right about right
about there and then when we are at 45
units our average variable cost is 200
it's at 45 units our average variable
cost is right over there and then add we
did that one and then at at 58 units its
207 58 units it is 207 so it's going to
be right about there and then at we did
this one and at 65 units it's 230 165 is
and then we get to 231 which is right
maybe about there and then as we did
this one and then at 70 units we're at
257 so 70 units 257 looks something like
this now before I actually draw in this
curve connect the dots let's just think
about how the average variable cost
relates to the marginal cost when the
marginal cost is less than the average
variable
cost well that means that as we do more
as we produce more and more our average
variable costs should go down and we see
that happening in this early stage I
won't go into all the details of what's
happening exactly right over there but
that early stage as we see that while
while our marginal cost is less than our
average variable costs our average
variable cost is trending down and that
makes sense every incremental unit is
getting is a little bit cheaper to
produce what brings down the average but
as soon as the marginal cross as soon as
the marginal curve crosses the average
variable cost and the marginal cost
every incremental unit is now more than
the average well that should bring up
the average and so then the average
variable cost should start sloping up so
it's good to realize one is a rule of
thumb but even more important to realize
why that where the marginal cost curve
and the average variable cost curve
intersect that that's going to be the
point at which the average variable cost
goes from trending down to trending up
if you view it as this very wide you
shape that would be the bottom of the U
and we could do the same thing with
average total costs now they're going to
cross a little bit later because the
average total costs are higher because
they're fracturing in the fixed costs as
well but you can imagine that while your
marginal costs are lower than your
average total cost every incremental
unit is going to bring down the average
total cost but as soon as the marginal
cost crosses the average total cost it's
going to start bringing up the average
and we can see that by trying to graph
average total cost and I'll do that in
this yellow color so at 25 units were at
for 40 25 units or at for 40 that makes
sense because we have all that fixed
cost that we're spreading along amongst
not that many units and then at 45 units
we're at 3 1145 we get to 311 might be
right around there then at 58 units
we're at 293 58 units we are at 293
which is right about there and then at
65 units were at 308
65 units we are at 308 and then at 70
units we're at 329 70 units we are at
329 so maybe something like this and so
this is our average total cost and just
as you could imagine while your marginal
costs every incremental unit the cost of
that is less than your average total
cost it'll bring down every when you do
that incremental output it will bring
down your average total costs until the
point that they cross and then now after
you craw after these two curves cross
now every incremental unit is bringing
up the average cost it's costing more
than the average and so once again where
these two curves intersect if you view
the average total cost curve is this big
wide you it would represent the bottom
of the you now the last thing that we
didn't graph and this is maybe the most
intuitive is the average fixed cost and
this is just going to ask them tote down
at 25 units were at 225 units we are at
200 at 45 units we're at 111 45 111 s
maybe right over there at 58 units were
at 86 58 units 86 at 65 units we're at
77 65 units 77 and then at 70 units were
at 71 and so you can see that that just
gets lower and lower and lower over as
you produce more and more output because
you're able to spread those fixed costs
amongst more and more output so that
makes sense that the average fixed cost
just trends downward like this the
entire time but the big takeaways here
is not just to understand the rule of
thumb that where the marginal cost curve
intersects the average variable cost or
the average total cost that that's the
you could view it as the minimum point
of the average total cost or the average
variable cost curves but to understand
why that is happening